let me help you out a little bit because
this next plug this is this is kind of a
piano fits right into what we're going
to be learning today let me rewind on
the bit let's just look at question 1 do
you all agree with another's yeah I know
some people with isn't really really a
doubt my calculator very much but 256 is
the square number 16 I'm 16
it'll give that bird back well you go
check that if you want it to what are
these threes about what do they change
about the funeral yeah okay so cute
words
how'd you just fine how'd you explain
what a cube root is to somebody's never
heard of what a cube root is knocking
yeah
so like this is 10 times 10 I'll give
you 100 cool so what's the difference
over here
yeah very good
so if you go 7 times 7 times 7 that
should give you 300 3 ok I hope you know
you've got that bit on your calculator I
where's the cube root because it's not
one of the buttons it's somewhere else
you gotta go shift and then cool so you
can see where it is and that'll be very
useful for us ok now actually while
we're looking your captain is key keep
it there because this is gonna be very
useful for us when we do this I heard
some people mention this before but one
of the quickest ways to be able to do
this but thoughtfully and efficiently is
to take all of these guys and convert
them into decimals okay hands up if you
already did that hands up okay so I need
a bit of um but it helps you to work
these out let's go three decimal places
three decimal places can someone tell me
what 3/7 is zero points yeah 48
I'll just put up put your guide it rads
up aha which Jake hopefully put on there
you don't need a calculator to work out
is zero point okay if you want to get
the accuracy sure we're talking about
that this got 6 elevenths just got it
right all right point 5 4 5 right okay
five nights five months July said again
zero point five five and this one again
you don't really need all right a minute
okay now moving from two major to be
right we know who's coincidentally I've
shown that those are in the right order
so we know which ones are bigger which
ones are smaller but now that we've got
decimal labels on these we're a bit
better equipped to work out okay which
ones are closer which one so far okay so
for example 0.5 is here right in the
middle so if you think about say 0.49
okay you need to look at how far you've
measured that on your page and I'm
looking everyone's done there's slightly
different lengths which is okay and they
need to come back well how far is your
good fortune I'm gonna be on your scale
so for example if this was 10
centimeters across 10 centimeters across
how far back am I gonna have to come in
order to make it accurately zero it
would be about if that was 10
centimeters this would be about 8 about
it now most of you don't have a diagram
quite that or a number line quite that
large which is fine so you're gonna
ratchet yours down a little bit I'm
gonna put mine on one if you want to
compare if your relative difference
isn't similar to mine so this is 3/7
these guys are going to be right nestled
up against each other maybe you're
having trouble putting two separate
lines but that's okay I'm going to put
the
here and here so let's make this 1 6 11
and this one 5 nights this guy here is
an easy way to work out roughly where
you should go
what's halfway between 0.5 and 1
what's the halfway between them that's
gonna be 0.75 right so therefore zero
point it's just gonna be just a little
over that so I'm gonna put that in there
for Fitz are you happy with that you go
to your relative positions there okay
now I don't you like you to rule that
off because we're going to start a new
topic today
hence the different kinds of review
questions we've been doing this is gonna
be a little tricky because I actually
need to refer to the stuff that's on the
board there are three questions that we
did so I'm going to change their heading
but I want you to still have what we
just did in front of you okay so now let
me mix in the space the header you can
make is introduction to CERN's s you are
and keep your calculator that it's gonna
be really hated right so you've
encountered sense before at least a
couple of years you've encountered them
because you've been doing this kind of
thing right so you did all these square
roots do all these cube roots but I
picked my numbers really deliberately
some of you worked this out
half way through doing the questions why
did I pick say it say these three
numbers why did I pick one hundred two
fifty six and nine what's special about
it so yeah when you take the square root
of these guys you just end up with
something nice in me okay one hundred
two fifty six and nine they're all
squares sixty-four and 343 what's
special about those two they are nice
neat cubes right I'll be exact numbers
okay and that's why your answers were
all so nice and neat however just grab
your k-cup calculator out and just
quickly check for yourself if you try
some numbers that are in between them
let's just change in number by one
don't take a square root of 100 take the
square root of like 101 okay
the square root of 101 ends up being
this gaudy mess you're gonna get a whole
bunch of decimal places all right who's
got it for you calculate on this screen
yeah give me all of it okay so your
calculators going to hand you those ten
or twelve decimal places to communi but
they really do go on forever now this is
really strange because do you remember
when you converted these back to
decimals you remember when we did that
so we could do this sound look at one
like say 611 ski-doo that one your
calculator again 6 elevenths okay if my
memory serves I think what you're
getting is five four five four five four
five and it just sort of does its theme
this is a special name when it repeats
over never again does anyone remember
it's called brain all right with art but
it's not quite as difficult as to do
with fractions anyone
curry recurring it's just another word
for repeating right and you can see
that's exactly what these numbers do
we're never there again in fact all of
them do can you do five bytes I'm pretty
sure it's five five five five it repeats
even more than the other one did okay
even if we'd won like three cents it
doesn't look like it repeats but just
like you I think what you're gonna get
from memory is four to eight five or
seven next five seven one yeah so close
okay one for now if you keep on going
your decimal places it starts to write
and your calculator can only give you
ten or twelve decimal places if you've
got a phone which also has a calculator
in it and you turn it sideways so
they'll give you more digits you'll find
those same six digits over and over
again all these guys repeat they
recurring for this guy square 101 square
102 anything you want to put that
doesn't give you a nice thing number it
never repeats and VAR that's really
weird
okay and that's what gets at the heart
of what a third is so underneath what
you've written that this is I have no
space but I want you to remember our
definition for serve is a square root or
a cube root or a fourth root fifth or
sixth root whatever kind of root that
does this see this non-repeating thing I
just sort of does its weird thing
forever that's a sir these ones we
started off with they're not certain why
not yeah they're whole numbers they just
stop in fact even if they're not whole
numbers go ahead and check this in your
calculator this is not a whole number
and when you put the square root in you
don't get a whole number but what do you
get
I think you get two and a half if my
memory serves okay so that stops see
that two and a half or two point five
you see it doesnt do that weird jazz
music jazz dancing on forever and doing
something different all the time it just
stops
so is this assert no it's these breed
objects that we're interested in is
because they are weird that we're
interested in them we didn't explore
them in this topic okay so let me say
that again in case you missed the
sentence our definition for a third is a
square root or a cube root or any kind
of root who's now here's a here's a
phrase for you which I along I'll write
on the board because it's important in a
bit unusual whose decimal expansion
that's what this thing is we converted
to a decimal that's what your calculator
helps you understand right
whose decimal expansion never repeats
let's see let me set up a long time
assert is square root or cube root or
any kind of root whose decimal expansion
never ever repeats and that's really
weird that's why they're their own topic
then we're going to look at over the
next week and a half okay